hi everyone how are you if you don't
know me my name is Gwen and I run a
YouTube channel called Faraday Academy
where I do mostly view Jas and Python
Django content videos and livestreams on
there and free code camp is letting me
stream from their channel again today
now last week I built one of the
projects the quote machine using basic
HTML and few Jas and I received some
comments and issues and one PR from that
so thank you for all your contributions
so I've updated it over the last week
and now this week I'm gonna be working
on the markdown previewer so here's the
repo I'm just gonna post it in the chat
and you can take a look that has all the
code from last week and also whatever
code that I write from today so yeah if
you don't know this is one of free code
camps projects they're front-end
projects that you usually build with
react on their platform but you can
really build it with any type of
JavaScript framework so today I'm going
to be using view and the view UI
framework inclined so it's similar to
bootstrap it's really good for
responsive design and it's also one of
the simpler frameworks but still robust
enough to have a grid system and a lot
of the components that you would need so
I'm going to be using this framework
today and yeah let me go into the
terminal so I have the main repo with
all the different markdown preview out
machine and all the different folders in
it so I'm gonna go into the markdown
previewer folder
all right let's see by the way if you're
here feel free to say hi make comments
suggestions anything during the stream
all right so now I have marked down
previewer and let me see what's in here
so right now it's just my read me and
mock up so I'm going to create an app
folder with my view app and today
instead of HTML I'm going to be using
the view CLI to create this so if you go
to the view j/s website you can just
install view with NPM if you want to
globally or use npx
and then you have access to the vcli so
I'm going to do view create a new app
and or should I call this I'll call this
markdown previewer invalid oh they can't
it can't contain capital letters alright
so let's see if that works
all right cool and now it's taking me
through asking me what options I want to
install so I'm just gonna do the default
because I'm not going to need routing
and state management and stuff all right
so that's installing it'll take a minute
and then I'll open this up in a code
editor let me go ahead and pull up the
inclined getting started so these are
all the ways that I can install it the
view CLI that should be the easiest so
I'm just gonna add this as a plug-in
right after I finish installing all
right I don't know if I'm seeing the
chat have there been any chat messages
let me see I guess not
okay so I move the
oh that's weird didn't realize it would
follow me around on different screens
that's interesting all right
stalling packages oh and the markdown
library I looked at a couple just to see
which ones were updated the markdown
library that I'm going to use is view
markdown the last update was about a
year and a half ago but it seems to
still be working well and it has a live
demo so this is the one I'm going to
install and use all right cool so now I
have the folder markdown previewer and
I'll go in there okay now I'm in my
folder and let me open my code editor
okay so let's see okay so now I have a
new view j/s application with the hello
world let me run this first actually so
let me do NPM run serve then I can open
it up in the browser localhost 8080 okay
cool so that's working now I'm gonna
have to stop the server because I want
to add Incline so I'm going to copy this
and stop the server and view add Incline
there are uncommitted changes yes I
still want to proceed because I haven't
done anything to the repo yet okay
so I'm installing incline and the next
thing I want to install before I rerun
the server is view markdown so I'm going
to go ahead and get the install for this
MPM install view markdown all right
so I don't know why it's showing this
other screen it's trying to see if there
was chat but that's okay I'll just be
talking to myself
let's see markdown preview okay so that
installed and now I'll do let's see oh
yeah let me run the server again and
it's building its building there you go
there we go
all right so now I'm going to start
setting up the component so in my if I
go into the markdown previewer in that
repo I have just a basic yeah just a
basic like side by side right markdown
and see the preview on the other side
and this is actually I looked back at my
old free code camp projects from five
years ago and this is the exact same
thing that I built in react five years
ago so I just borrowed the same design
basically for this one so let me go to
Incline actually and I'm gonna set up
the grid system for the page so this is
exactly like bootstrap column-wise so it
has 12 columns and everything and let me
just okay let me just take the grid all
of the components for inclined are
wrapped in I so it's just like most
other view frameworks
like beautifies V - container element is
e - container and incline is I -
container alright so let me actually
copy all of this The Container row and
column and I'll go to the app component
and now I'm gonna delete everything
that's in there and I'm also going to
delete hello world
delete the component and delete all of
this styling that I'm not going to need
alright so in here let me do loops do an
eye container Iroh and let me close the
container okay so now I have a row and
in this row I want to have two columns
because I want a column for this big
text field where I input the markdown
and the formatted text on the other side
so let me go ahead and add that so yeah
a different column so I'll do actually
I'll just copy that okay so now I have
two columns and inside of the first
column and actually I don't want these
to be full width so this is taking up
all twelve columns so I'm gonna put from
small screen size up let's see to take
up six columns alright and then the same
thing on this one so they're small and
then I'll take up six columns
alright cool and now inside of the first
one let me find a text area in Incline
so let me look for text
area all right
so it's not closing there we go
so clearable tux disabled I just want
the basic text area
let me grab this one and eventually I'll
set a height on it okay let me grab that
and then basically just need to v-model
it somewhere so let's see the model 2
value so I need to create a value so let
me add a value variable in data it's too
much okay so let me add data function
and return the data variable which will
be an empty string to start with and put
that on separate lines make it a little
bit nicer okay let's see I'm gonna put
ENTER mark down here and it's models to
the value which oh I accidentally put
data there let me put let me actually
put text there so now it's text and let
me check see if that's working okay cool
so I can enter something here and then
in my view dev tools I should be able to
see the text here I container I roll I
call them I text okay so in the app
component I can see the let me move my
face I can see the data is equal to
whatever I type in its mapping
okay so the two-way data-binding is
working and now I need to put some kind
of a margin top to bring this down and
also a vertical divider in between both
columns it's already giving me because
I'm using the container element it's
already giving me a nice let's see
container
yeah it's giving me a really nice margin
on the outside so I just need that same
margin on the top really so let me add
that on the container I'm gonna add a
clasp and let me just look in Incline
what the spacing actually I'll search
for it let me see if they have spacing
oops
spacing or margin okay so it has SAS SAS
variables that I can use SAS variables
for spacing okay now I wonder if I put
SAS and oh no I didn't actually install
SAS with this app that's fine I'll add
my own spacing in that case because when
I set up the vcli I just set up the
default so there's just linting and
stuff basically so let me do style and
[Music]
I'll give this a class of I guess I'll
just call it container and I'm gonna
style that container so style the
container as margin top of 40 pixels
okay that adds some margin top and then
I'm going to add a title here so I can't
remember what I did on the mock-ups I
think I just said markdown okay let me
add that title then it'll be in the same
column right above the text area so I'll
do h1 markdown okay I think that looks
pretty good and now I have this and now
let me add the vertical line here so
let's see if it has a vertical line
vertical vertical grid flex okay well I
guess not
so that's fine I guess I'll add that
later let me then just copy this title
and then I'll put formatted formatted
text here okay
so that's fine and then I'll add I guess
a border to one of the one of the sides
and hope that it's even let's see in the
column so I should add it to the column
I guess so if I add a border here let me
just try it out in the browser so let me
move one second let me there if I can
oh there we go alright so let me add a
border
right of one pixel solid okay I think
that looks pretty good because of the
padding that that the columns are giving
me so it's pushing it it's giving it the
same amount of padding pretty much on
either side I think so though okay so
now I have to add that here and so let
me add four column here let me add a
custom class I'll just call it column
and then down here I'm gonna add that
column and I'll say what it was at
border right of one pixel solid oh yeah
semicolon there okay and that should
default to black
oh no okay so I think so this must have
the same class of column because it's
giving me two so I thought maybe
inclined would give it a class of I
column or something but no it's just
column which is fine so let me give it
I'll just call it custom no no let me
call it something what I'm actually
doing with it let me call it order right
and then I'll update this down here to
border right all right okay cool so now
it has the border let me set a height on
this then on the input so let me go back
to text text area and I'll search for
height nope
so I might have to just set the height
attribute sizes this is just setting the
text sizes yeah it doesn't seem like
they have a prop they accept a prop for
height so I guess that's just styling
which makes sense so I text area let me
put a class here which will be text area
[Music]
or I'll call it text area height all
right so here I'll do a class text area
height and then let me say height is I
don't know 400 pixels let's see that
that looks like oh wait I didn't save oh
wait I made a typo there okay so 400
pixels well that changed the vertical
line but it didn't really change this
the text area so I wonder if I just pass
in let me see let me edit the HTML here
so if I just say height directly inside
the element I think I can do 400 nope
because it's draggable but I'd rather
just have the height I might have - oh
that's kind of cool
you can just drag it doesn't expand past
its container good so let me look up
real quick
text setting text area height
should I size taqueria so it seems like
you can just do width and height yeah
why can't I use width and height am I
doing this wrong you have 400 pixels and
let me just do a text area class cuz
text area height as a class seems weird
okay so I have a text area now let me
refresh okay well it's not changing the
height I can try one more thing
otherwise I'll just move on
let me try setting height directly here
because maybe it's just an undocumented
API I don't know okay no that didn't
work get rid of that all right so I'll
just leave that alone for now then and
figure out how to do that later
anyway so I have the text from here and
now I need to get the mark or turn it
into formatted mark down on this side so
let me so I already installed the
markdown library so actually I need to
pull in the component so let me just
look at the markdown library okay so I
just import it import the component and
then register it as a component so let
me copy that and then oh it's so in
script I'll import markdown and then
here I can register you markdown okay
cool and then it's basically saying to
pass in the markdown text into the
component so into the default slot so
I'll just copy this and put it right
here okay first let me see if this
displays on the page so let's see can't
resolve double one time that's
interesting
Babel doesn't seem to have anything to
do with this markdown previewer
let me see yeah it's just saying to
install view markdown and nothing else
okay let me look in the issues what is
it saying module will not found error
can't resolve Babel runtime core get
iterator okay so let me copy this real
quick and here nope let me see
module not found let me see what is in
the terminal these dependencies were not
found Babel runtime all right let me try
typing that in so these dependency or
let me just type in babble babble
runtime cannot find module babble
runtime all right this is electron but
that's I mean that's the same error I'm
getting delete node modules didn't seem
to work for people there's a popular
answer npm install saved up let's see
yeah I guess that makes sense
install Babel runtime and I wonder why
they wouldn't list it as a dependency
they had to install and let me let me
install that I guess on solid is a
regular dependency if this library is
going to need it all the time so let me
see the install Babel runtime
all right
installing all right now let me try
running the dev server again water
all right
still okay let's see if that works
okay sweet so this is good it's showing
the markdown that I passed in here of
course it's not real markdown let me
write something in markdown and see let
me just make this text bold so now the
default should be bold and it's not bold
okay it's bold now I had to refresh all
right cool
so the markdown is working now I just
have to get this text inside of this
markdown field so let me just see if I
can pass in the v-model
so my text variable and it doesn't seem
to be updating so let me set a default
text here and see if that works let me
do hello there okay cool
oh yeah oh yeah that's right I was like
how did I tip it in there because it's V
modeling to text okay so I think it just
doesn't update as I'm typing it's not
the v-model should be updating so let me
look let me make sure that the model is
updating my view dev tools in my app
component yeah so the V model is
updating my dad my text variable is
updating but it's not showing new output
here so I wonder how I can get it to
re-render where's my library let's see
I'm guessing there's something here
about rerun during the disk folder
contains view okay okay I think this is
it watches which is an array HTML
refresh automatically when the prop and
this array changes okay I think this is
what I want then let me just see source
I wonder so I think instead of using a
default slot maybe I can pass in the
string as source but in slots I could
probably do things like emojis I'm not
sure actually let me just see with
watches let me pass an array to it so
let me go let's see let me go to my
markdown and put this on two lines and
watches equals a one second
okay cool so that worked I just wanted
to fix the display but I think that
zoomed in a little bit too okay
so now let me come back to watches and
oh wait I need to pass an array here so
this should be JavaScript oops and I
think the syntax is all right so let's
see if this works
let me pass in text and let me refresh
nope it doesn't work so the syntax must
be let me just see so I'm passing in
this prop watches to text so when the
text variable changes the HTML should
rerender but it's not so let's see what
am I doing wrong
enable HTML syntax okay so these are all
defaults to true anyway
[Music]
dispatch memorandum finishes these are
the events so I don't want to watch for
the events let me see
well let me see if they have yeah they
have an example folder so let me go into
the example if index.html and okay yeah
so instead of the slot they're passing
in the string as source amazing been
here the passing in the string is source
anchor oh here okay so there's like four
different examples here oh they have a
lot of different examples okay
let's see set interval mounted this dot
source but this I think oh so this set
interval I think is telling it it's
updating this dot source every time so I
wonder if I put it if I pass it in as
source if it's gonna watch for changes
let me try that let me get rid of that
and watches and then do source as text
and then I'm gonna find that you find
that okay so now let's see if that's
watching for changes I don't know yeah
sweet okay cool
that was easy so now if I press enter
enter and let me do header oh cool
awesome that wasn't too bad I had her
too and then I can do checklist
awesome it's completely functional
markdown sweet that wasn't too bad let's
see what could I change yeah in the
mock-ups for some reason I thought maybe
I'm gonna want to click format manually
but actually I think this is good that
it just automatically updates and
previews that's much better than
clicking a button ok cool
so um let me just see if I can get this
to set a height for some reason I'm not
sure okay style height is changing as I
drag it the style height so I wonder
because when I search for a height here
I'm textarea just doesn't say anything
about setting the height even in the
examples oops did I do something okay my
screen just went funny all right
so even in the examples no I'm caught up
on the height of the text field so I
felt I feel like I should be able to
just set it well here I mean it's
setting it on style so I have a class of
text area so let's let me see if I can
set height
I have 400 pixels here I wonder if
that's being overwritten by incline
though by the incline framework this is
so weird let me try putting a regular
text area just outside of the container
I'm gonna say text text area and yeah
just a plain text area oh let me give it
a class let's say class of text area
where is it yeah this one this regular
plain text area I have is 400 pixels so
it's something about incline that's not
accepting that class let me try one more
thing let me try to use a class that
they're already but I guess they aren't
designing a class to it yeah
Oh
because form input so there's a wrapper
class around it they wrap it in form
input group and then they wrap it in
form input so let me try to change the
height of one of the other ones oh let
me try to change this one okay so if I
change
apparently so if I change form input the
wrapper around text area that should be
good
so let me access or reference the form
input class and I'll get rid of this
extra class okay let me see if that
works it still doesn't work form input
so I think I need to I'm gonna try one
more thing so is this set this as a
module no I can't remember so there was
something that you could do for
dynamically updated classes actually I
wonder if inclined takes a set of
classes that you can pass in let me
search nope they don't have anything
about classes here so I guess the only
thing with inclined is to
[Music]
yeah basically update the staffs sass
variables which I don't have sass in my
application though I did yeah when I I'm
importing all of the sass variables here
and registering the components and
everything okay so let me think I think
there's so there's something in view for
CSS and I think it's called module view
the CSS module in component it's been so
long since I use this maybe it wasn't
called module
let's see I'm looking for the style tag
yeah it is called module okay CSS
modules then add the module attribute
okay then it should be available on this
let me zoom in it should be available
now on the dollar sign style what if
that's gonna change in v3 let me try
that so this style tag is scoped so I'm
gonna add another style tag that I will
put as a module oops
so style mod module and close it and now
let me take this and here I'm gonna put
text area and height of 400 pixels okay
let me just make sure they're defining
it as a class yeah they are they're
defining it as a class so let me try
that let me now go to text area and do
class equals style dot text area and
actually I'm thinking this might not
work because I'm passing this into ink
line and I don't know which of the three
Dom elements it renders are gonna get
that class I have no idea all right so
let me try
yeah I think it's giving the class to a
different element which is let's see app
text area
yeah it's giving the class to the parent
element not to the child elements so
this form input group is getting the
class but I need it on form input all
right I guess the only other thing I can
try is to see if someone else has had
this issue on incline
let's see text area height
and nobody nobody nobody nobody's even
said anything about textarea all right
so that's something that I will have to
figure out after the stream or someone
has a recommendation then you can let me
know about it oh well yeah so I think
this is pretty much it if there are no
comments in the chat then I think I'll
just go ahead and push this code and
yeah let me stop the View server if we
do get status markdown preview
oh right right so when I created a
generated a view project in this
directory I thought it created a new get
for me but I guess it didn't because the
parent has a git directory as a git
project already so let me go up and up
to my free code camp projects and now
the git status get add this new project
that I have commit code from live stream
on June 25th for markdown previewer okay
that looks good now I'll push it
okay and sweet so now I have the
markdown prove your code from today
all right so if there are no comments or
chat messages it was a very quiet day
next week I'll be building the drum
machine at the same time if you want to
tune in for that and yeah feel free to
make a comment raise an issue on this
repo and yeah give me feedback or
whatever I'll be doing the view CLI
again for the drum machine next week and
then for I guess the rest of the free
code camp projects they get a little bit
more complicated with each one so I'll
start adding in other things like be
router view X and maybe even by the end
of this we three will will come out so
then I can do something with v3 yeah so
thanks for watching everyone if you were
snooping and watching I can't see who's
watching or anything but I hope you
enjoyed this got something out of it I
don't forget to check out my channel
Faraday Academy and have a great day
everybody
take care